Jules is widely considered one of the
best thrillers ever made but it almost
never happened at all
from budget problems to cast feuds and
Oscar snubs we're diving deep into the
waters of a movie that started with
notorious production problems but
finished with rave reviews three Academy
Awards and a whole bunch of cash he is
the untold truth of Jaws unfinished
script one of the early signs our
production on jaws wouldn't run as
smoothly as planned came from the script
which passed through the hands of three
writers jaws novelist Peter Benchley
playwright Howard Sackler and comedy
writer called Gottlieb Gottlieb told the
Los Angeles Times in 2015 Benchley was a
journalist who didn't understand
screenplays Sackler did a workman like
job of translating the novel faithfully
a faithful rendition of the novel was
not what was needed something else was
needed and I came on board Gottlieb
wound up removing a number of subplots
from bench Lee's novel and adding a dose
of humor to the script ultimately
creating the story that made it on
screen broken shark choosing to film out
in the ocean and not in a Hollywood
studio tank created a number of
headaches for the cast and crew however
a few things were more frustrating and
costly than the film's mechanical shark
according to Mental Floss the Sharks
sank to the bottom of the Nantucket
Sound on its first day of shooting and
you could hear basically every day you
could hear this the fishy villain
nicknamed Bruce on sets continued to
malfunction forcing Steven Spielberg and
his team to figure out how to film most
of the movie without the shark and as it
turns out the shark free approach worked
and Spielberg later admitted that had
the shark been working perhaps the film
would have made half the money and been
half as scary production was between
mechanical sharks are sinking to the
bottom of the ocean and the boats
flooding mid-scene Jaws seemingly
endless production woes ate into the
film's production schedule and budget to
the point where some members of the cast
crew and executive team thought the
movie would ruin their careers in the
studio was running out of patience
there's no question about it and things
were you know atmosphere was getting a
little tense according to BuzzFeed jaws
started with a budget of 3.5 million
dollars and the 55 day production
schedule but ultimately cost about 9
in dollars and took over a hundred and
fifty nine days to complete to this day
this production haunt Spielberg who said
a hundred days over schedule or the
water it was insane I almost got fired
probably nineteen times it was almost my
epilogue you know he made jaws of course
jaws became the highest-grossing movie
of 1975 and remains one of the most
financially successful movies of all
time but nobody knew that back then
actor Feud much like the carrots as they
played actors Robert Shaw and Richard
Dreyfuss did not get along drawing much
of the shooting of Jaws what caused the
feud
according to co-star Roy Scheider sure
initially took issue with Dreyfus as
pompous attitude about filming a movie
showed a record in the Biography Channel
documentary Joseon Side Story
sure really thought Dreyfus needed a
slapping down that he was a young punk
with no stage experience things only got
worse from there
their feud reached a boiling point when
Dreyfus threw a glass of bourbon that
sure had been drinking out the window
Spielberg remembers a moment well that
was the shot heard around the world
the duo eventually made amends during
the filming of quints famous USS
Indianapolis speech again much like
their characters and the speaking of the
scene drunk on set one of the key
turning points in Jaws comes when Shaw's
character quince delivers a harrowing
monologue about the time he battled
tiger sharks in the water after the USS
Indianapolis was torpedoed by the
Japanese Navy but actually filming the
iconic moment wasn't exactly easy
because sure was too drunk to say his
lines
Spielberg told Ain't It Cool News I
guess he had more than a few drinks
because the two crew members actually
had to carry him to hit onto the Orca
and help him into his chair and I had
two cameras on the scene and Lee and we
never got through the scene he was just
to work on
iconic ad-lib although Quinn speech
remains one of the great movie
monologues of all times it inevitably
pales in comparison to Jaws most iconic
line we wouldn't need a bigger boat
according to screenwriter Cole Gottlieb
the line was a running joke on set
because everybody thought the barge
carrying the productions lighting a
camera equipment and craft services was
too small
Richard zanuck and David Brown were very
stingy producers so everyone kept
telling them you're gonna need a bigger
boat it became a catchphrase for anytime
anything went wrong if lunch was late or
the swells were rocking the camera
someone would say you're gonna need a
bigger boat Gottlieb added that Scheider
liked to ad-lib the line at various
points during production including the
now famous scene no sequel for Spielberg
after jaws went on to make a boatload of
money the inevitable sequel tour came
into play by that point however
Spielberg was done with the franchise
he told Ain't It Cool News I was done I
was done with the ocean I would have
done the sequel if I hadn't had such a
horrible time at sea on the first film
still that doesn't mean he hasn't
revisited the story on occasion he added
I have a very very good scene which I
thought would have been good for a
sequel someday every time I think of the
scene I think mmm could this be another
jaws movie and they have to immediately
pull myself back down to earth ask a
snob when award seasons rolled around
after jaws release Spielberg was so
convinced that he was going to be
nominated for an Oscar that he hired a
camera crew to film him watching the
nominations on television jaws is about
to be nominated in 11 categories you're
about to see a sweep of the nominations
turns out Spielberg was a little too
optimistic the film wound up receiving
only four nominations and although it
went on to win three Spielberg was upset
that he wasn't nominated for Best
Director for jaws calling the decision
commercial backlash when a film makes a
lot of money people resented everybody
everybody loves a winner that may be
true but nobody loves the soul loser
either thanks for watching click the
loop icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know your love to
[Music]